You know what they say, more money more problems,
well what about more money more sex?
Hey guys, Julia here for Dnews
A recent study from Anglia Ruskin University
in Cambridge, England found a link between
income and sex.
Oooh exciting right?
But before we talk about sex, let’s talk
about subscribing
We know you’re curious about getting it
on, so get your subscribe on so you don’t
miss an episode of DNews.
We’ve also got a playlist filled with videos
all about the sexy times.
Check out links for that down in the description
below.
Now that you’ve subscribed, let’s get
to back to the subject of sex.
In a study published in the International
Journal of Manpower, researchers reviewed
data from 75-hundred participants and found
those who had sex two or three times a week
made 4.5% more income than their less frisky
coworkers.
Even those who weren’t in perfect health
still benefited from a higher salary, they
earned 1.5% than their similarly less fit
coworkers.
The lead researcher from the study says the
data supports the idea that more money, means
more sex and vice versa, that having more
sex might give you a boost in the boardroom.
Okay okay.
I know.
Correlation does not equal causation.
So let’s break this down.
Sex might be good for us for all sorts of
reasons.
Some doctors say its relaxation effects help
soothe stress.
Small studies like one published in the journal
Biological Psychology suggests it helps lower
blood pressure spikes.
Other research shows that pleasureable actvities,
like sex, reduce stress.
And another study from the Archives of Sexual
Behavior shows that sex lowers anxiety and
can boost your mood the next day.
These mental health benefits might make us
more alert on the job and ready to tackle
any challenges with ease.
Maybe frequent sex is the sign of a strong
relationship and strong relationships also
have health benefits.
According to the journal BMC Public Health,
people who are satisfied in their relationships
have a kind of buttress against emotional
distress.
Or another way of looking at it, maybe getting
it on more often is a vote of confidence.
If you’re getting lucky at home, maybe that
leaves a little more pep in your step when
you head to work.
Some research from the University of Melbourne
showed that self-confidence is a key determinant
of workplace success.
When you feel better about yourself you’re
more likely to do a better job.
Or maybe you know, it’s the other way around.
It could be that healthier people do better
in the workplace and healthier people also
happen to have more sex.
The same study in the Journal of International
Manpower found that people without disabilities
are 13% more sexually active than those with
disabilities and people with heart disease
have 11.4% less sex than their healthier peers.
Studying the link between health and sex and
status is surprisingly difficult.
Most studies rely on self-reporting, so you
know, people don’t always tell the truth.
Especially when it comes to a subject as touchy
as sex.
I guess you could say….
More research is needed.
On the topic of sex research, did you know
that funny people get laid more?
Trace and I explore that connection in this
video:
Oh come on, i know...we’re all curious about
sex and we all know that what you learn in
health class might not be all that.. er…
factual.
And here at DNews we’ll stick to the science.
So if you’ve got questions, I know you do,
leave ‘em down in the comments below.
if you haven’t already, go ahead and like
this video and subscribe to our channel so
you don’t miss an episode.